[Music]
Dave Ramsey here and welcome to real
estate the Ramsey way it's no secret
that getting ready to buy a home takes
some hard work and one of the hardest
parts that always comes with a lot of
questions is saving for a down payment I
mean that's a lot of money but when you
set clear goals and you save up the
right amount and make a plan the home
buying process will go a whole lot
smoother for you so check out these
questions from home buyers all about
what to do next once you're ready to buy
a home Matt is in Pittsburgh hey Matt
welcome to the ramsy
show hey Dave it's an honor to be
speaking with you today you too what's
up um well I'm currently a 22-year-old
college student um I'll be graduating
here in the next couple months and I'm
looking to get out of my renting
situation and purchase a home within the
next year I'm kind of lost on um how to
really save up for it if I should be
keeping all my um
like income that I'm going to be having
in cash or if I should be investing it
and how much you recommend to put down
on my first home purchase I'm just kind
of looking for some guidance here cool
so what's your income
Matt um well currently I don't have any
but I'll be starting a job in June that
um I'll be making uh 70,000 in my first
year plus um 10K in stock but I'm pretty
sure I don't get paid that until like a
year year and a half okay and do you
have any debt right
now um I have I have a good amount of
savings and personal Investments but I
do have $9,000 left on a car P okay and
that's all the debt that's all the debt
so what's stopping you from paying off
the car today and freeing up that
payment um I well I um I I was fortunate
enough not to have to pay for my college
because I got a athletic scholarship so
because of that um my dad we bought a
car together together well it's in my
name but we bought it together during Co
so there's um no interest on it it was
like one of those deals I know you
probably won't like hearing that but uh
I don't know I just haven't put it as a
first priority just because I don't
really want to use my um I've about like
11,000 in savings right now and I kind
of don't have an income these next
couple months so I've just been avoiding
it I guess how much have you got in
personal
Investments um around 17 okay and is
that in retirement
account uh no it's actually in
individual stocks and yeah basically all
stocks and a little bit of
cryptocurrency okay well mat I'll tell
you what we teach and this is the
process I followed to get through all
the baby steps and now with the paid for
house baby step one is the th000
emergency fund baby step two we pay off
all of our debt using the debt snowball
method and that includes the car baby
step three we get 3 to 6 months of
expenses in an emergency fund and then
baby step 3B we start saving up for the
house and so that's where that would
fall in and so you're you're not quite
there yet you could be if we released
these Investments cashed out and started
doing things a different way uh but it
sounds like you're you're good with
Matt's plan which is fine but if you're
going to buy a house here's our
parameters for it in that 3B I want you
to save up 10 to 20% for your down
payment on a 15-year fixed mortgage that
should be your only option when it comes
to mortgages and the take your uh
payment on that should be no more than a
quarter of your take-home pay so you can
jump to our mortgage calculator at
Ramsey solutions.com and start playing
around with those numbers to see hey in
the Pittsburgh area for a reasonable
house for me for you know my my first
house what do I need to do okay I need
to save up $70,000 in order to get this
house on a 15-year fixed rate where the
payments no more than a quarter of my
take home
pay gotcha and Matt you're so once I pay
off the car sorry what was that go ahead
go ahead so once I once I pay up the car
and save enough for to put 20% down and
my take pay it's U my monthly payment is
a quarter of my KC comp pay and I'm good
to go on a 15year yeah and you could I
mean today if you paid off the car you'd
still have money left over for your
emergency fund and then you can start to
save up for this down payment we just
got to start doing things in the right
order so that you feel this
progress gotta okay so here here's the
thing um you've listened to the show I
can tell by the way you're responding to
some of these things and you kind of
knew what we were going to say didn't
you yeah a little bit all right and so
here's the data the actual facts not
Theory not a Ramsey opinion but the
actual
facts we did the largest study of
millionaires ever done in North America
10,167 of them the number of them that
became millionaires using Bitcoin was
precisely
zero the number of them that used single
stocks playing a day trader game was
under
5% in other words 95% of them did not
use your
plan right so you need to decide if your
plan sucks as bad as I think it
does well would you recommend cashing
out of my individual stocks in crypto
and keeping that apparently cash
apparently that's what I just told you
so don't invest that in anything else
keep it sitting in cash until you need
an emergency fund of 3 to six months of
expenses and you need to be debt-free
paying off that stupid car by the end of
the
day and then you start then you start
building in cash your down payment on
your house and then when you get your
house you start putting 15% of your
income away into good grow stock mutual
funds in your 401k at your new great job
and you're going to be a millionaire
doing that by the time you're
35 he says I'm 45 years old I'm married
with two children under 12 and
completely debt free I took a new job a
year and a half ago making 100K a year
and my wife is a stay-at-home mom the
nature of my job requires me to be on
call and close to work leaving me little
choice but to pay a premium rent of
2,000 per month we are currently
watching the housing market and still
learning the area and are scking money
away to buy a home I have 45,000 in the
bank doing nothing for me but I've been
hesitant to invest as we would like to
have the money available should a home
come up that we can buy I've been told
that cash in Savings in a savings
account is like melting ice what do I do
with it h well in this situation you
know when it comes to saving uh for a
house it's a little bit different than
just you know any other money that
you're putting aside you know typically
we wouldn't invest uh the money that
you're saving for a house unless you
know the timeline is you know 5 years or
more although Dave I've heard you say
that a lot of times you'll just pop some
money in an index fund and let it sit
there and grow if you you know know what
you might use it for I particularly
don't have the stomach for that I'd
probably put it in hysa and just get the
best return on it that I possibly could
uh for the time being because it sounds
like you're kind of in that moment where
if the right thing comes open you're
ready to jump on it so yeah I would keep
it out of the market and I would put it
in a high yield savings account maybe
put it you know I've heard Dave say that
he'll put it in a CD that sort of thing
yeah high yield savings account like you
said it's perfect um it's not melting
ice when you are getting ready to use
the
money and you're getting ready to use
this money and so if you were going to
leave it in a stupid savings account for
10 years then yeah it is melting ice but
that's not your description you're in
the housing market you're ready to buy
and get rid of this premium rent and
everything else so yeah you definitely
go that route it it's you're not doing
the wrong thing now Jade I did have a
young guy come in uh all the work I've
done over the years with different NFL
and and other professional athletes um
they just happen to be listening to the
show and say hey would you look at my
stuff yeah I look at your stuff so it's
always interesting stories and of course
we've run into all the negative stories
where they've uh burned through all the
money you know I made $100 million I got
nothing to show for it or whatever that
kind of stuff I've met those guys and
there's always a lot of Shame and stuff
on those guys but in the in the in the
light of what Ryan is
saying this guy comes in he's young I
mean he's like 20 oh well 28 years old
maybe 26 years old he' been he'd been in
the league a few years but not you know
he wasn't an old guy in the league by
any stretch and his sweet little wife
and uh they they drive in in a used van
wow and they come in and they go like
Dave you're going to kill us we've
messed up and I'm thinking they're going
to tell me they've blown all their money
and he goes I I you're you're just going
to be so mad at me and I'm like I number
one I'm not going to be mad at you
regardless how dumb you are but what did
you do I mean did you do something dumb
he goes yeah we've got all our money in
savings account and I said uh how much
money do you have in savings account uh
36 million oh whoa and I'm like no I am
not going to yell at you I'm going to
hug you because you did everything right
but one tiny thing you actually you're a
pro athlete who has money you know what
this is a unicorn I mean you're
incredible way to go you're amazing I'm
so proud of you you actually lived on
less than you make you're driving a used
car you're not trying to impress your
posy you know you're you're out you
didn't buy your mother a house you
couldn't afford to buy her all the
stupid but stuff I usually run into you
have $36 million and the only thing you
did wrong was you didn't invest it no
you you get a hug you don't get a
yelling you know so but yeah in his case
he is melting ice for sure he doesn't
need to get that money invested so he
was wrong but not on the get yelled at
wrong side though the smart side way to
go man I mean absolute
stud believe it or not saving for a home
isn't impossible especially when you
have a plan check out our free guide and
learn how to break down your savings
goal into simple steps so you can buy a
home with confidence find our free
saving for a down payment guide at ramsy
solutions.com downpayment or click the
link in the show notes Jacob is with us
in Seattle hi Jacob how are
you I'm doing well Dave Ken thanks for
taking my call I appreciate it sure
what's
up all right so um me and my wife uh are
currently have no doubt uh looking to
purchase a house in the upcoming couple
years we have a little bit of a
disagreement on how we are going to be
saving the money um I'm I have a higher
risk appetite than she does I would like
to put it into like a diversified ETFs
and try to get a little try to get the
money to work for us for the upcoming
few years before we purchase and she
would like to put it into a high yield
savings account so we know exactly where
we're going to be in three years um how
would you suggest to go
about finding a compromise with that
well I think what you both need to
realize is that this decision is not
going to keep you from buying a house
or cause you to be able to buy a house
so let's do the math for a second and
I'll show you what I'm talking about how
much are you talking about
saving um we would like I would like to
purchase a house that we're going to be
in for the next 30 40 basically their
lifetime so good luck with that but yeah
it usually doesn't work that way but but
how much are you talking about saving in
the next three
years uh about 200,000 okay and so if
you make 10% on this money you're going
to make 20,000 bucks if you put it in a
high yield savings you're going to make
nothing and you'll lose 20,000 bucks but
200,000 is what's going to cause you to
be able to buy the house and 220 is not
going to cause you to buy a
substantially different house so the
fact that you made a little money on
your money is more of an intellectual
exercise than a factual change in your
situation okay that makes sense I'm
following you okay and so uh and the
same thing's true with her let's say you
put it into an ETF and it did not make
10% a year you had a bad three-year run
in the stock market stock market in
general was down you got tagged you know
in the face with this thing which could
happen in a three-year swing and uh you
don't have 200,000 you end up with
180,000 so you actually lost money you
follow me still doesn't keep you from
buying a house so my point is your
concern that you're not making a bunch
of money is somewhat mathematically
invalid her concern that you're going to
lose so much that you're going to not be
able to get a house is also not really
mathematically valid this is all more
about emotion than it is actual
dollars okay yeah that makes sense I'm
following you yeah so anyway all that to
say how do we solve this um probably at
our house uh we'd probably end up
splitting the baby we'd probably get let
me do uh put $100,000 over in
Investments and she'd put 100,000 over
there and at the end we would see who
won the
betat so you would say put it do a 5050
down the middle yeah yeah I don't think
there's anything wrong with that at all
because but again before you do this
both of you need to really own the fact
that this is not going to cause you to
buy a house or not buy a
house it's just more of an argument over
how we park the
money so I I got a weigh in here you
know look I I think you do exactly what
Dave just laid out walk her through that
both sides of the coin then I would see
how she's reacting to that and if her
safety gland is still
flaring I'm going with mama you know
what happy wife happy life that's the
other alternative that's the other
alternative yeah you don't lose on that
one because if you win if you put it all
in there and you go down 30 grand I told
you that's going to cost you 30 years of
remembering that yeah
that's the truth and maybe some jewelry
going to cost you $1,000 a year in
memory that's my remember back in all 23
when you didn't do what I said do I this
is they have memories oh they have
memories like have nothing on women yeah
this is true they remember forever
especially when they're right that's
even more devastating which again if you
want to most of the time actually that's
what you need to come to that conclusion
as well so this is not even a
mathematical question a virtuous wife
for her worth is far above rubies the
heart of her husband safely trusts her
and he will have no lack of gain so at
our house we probably today we would
split the baby 20 years ago when we were
still a little fresher the the the
nerves were still a little more raw
after going broke we probably would have
parked it yeah in a high yield savings
and not taking any risk cuz Sharon was
so
terrorized yes emotionally by what we
went through
that it took a decade for her to go and
we had to have a big old pile of money
to where she could go oh if you screw
that up over there it ain't going to
kill us and she's still one of the most
frugal people I know oh my God the woman
pick up an old used golf ball like no
one I have ever seen we have a
collection of old used golf balls over
the weed she's going to get bit by a
snake getting a getting a golf ball
that's worth 50 cents because it's
already been hit by the mower it's
unbelievable the woman is oh gosh yes
she no frugal frugal don't even touch it
yeah hi Josh how are you doing great how
are you doing Dave better than I deserve
what's up so question for you my wife
and I have a household income of just
over 100,000 and we're completely
through baby steps one through three and
I'm wondering how with the current house
market we don't have a home are saving
up for a home how do baby steps four and
five change for
us why would they change
well we are just saving up for home and
working towards that down payment we're
almost ready for the down payment okay
have you ever talk heard us talk about
the thing we call baby step
3B I have heard a little bit yes okay
that's what you're talking about I think
okay so you finish your emergency fund
at three that is the point at which you
would begin to save for your home and
some people Push pause and don't do four
and don't start saving for retirement
until they build their fully until they
get their house down payment some people
save for a house while they're putting
something in retirement up to 15% for
baby step four so you can do either one
or both somewhere in there so how long
is this going to take to save up your
down payment uh spefic goal so I
thinking mid next year we're going to
have uh a little bit larger down payment
than is required and we're doing 8% of
our household income into rths right now
okay and so while doing 8% % you'll
still have that down payment by mid next
year yeah we're putting away 8% into the
roths and about 40% of savings just goes
away into CDs until we're ready for a
down payment that's fabulous Josh well
done yeah that's what we would call baby
step 3B so 3B is all of your savings
goes into um into your house down
payment fund up are down to a little bit
less a little bit less a little bit less
than all because you're putting some or
up to 15% into retirement so you're
putting eight into retirement and you're
still going to make your down payment
goals doesn't change a thing is exactly
what I would do have at it okay and then
would you hold off at all until interest
rates come down or just when we get that
down payment ready no buy house when
you're ready okay because here's the
thing if interest rates come down after
you buy the house
refinance house prices aren't coming
down we've not seen substantial drops in
house prices ever in the real estate
Market except during the 2008 debacle
and we're not going to see them now
we've told you this for two years
because we've still got a shortage of
housing there's not enough inventory too
many buyers chasing too few items causes
price to maintain stability or go up so
house pric is going to be going up and I
wouldn't sit around and watch the house
prices go up while I'm waiting on
interest rates to go down bad plan I
don't time the stock market or the real
estate
market exactly both involve some risk
and here the only time I would time the
real estate Market is if I can't find a
deal when I'm buying investment property
and then wait cuz the Market's like
white hot and there is no deals I'm just
don't buy unless I get a good good deal
period I do not buy investment property
unless I steal it period I want to get a
great Buy on investment property your
money's made at the Buy on that but as
far as your personal residence goes buy
when you're ready which is when you're
debt free have your emergency fund in
place and have saved your down payment
yeah and I get interest rates have got
people freaked out because you know it's
hundreds of dollars more in your payment
and they're going well I need to wait
the problem like you're saying Dave is
those same people are going to call us
and say Dave I weighed and now the home
price is 100,000 more than it was well
and there's no guarantee interest rates
come
down I mean we saw the the FED what if
you sat around and waited and they went
to 10 yeah they just raised the rates
again so we just don't know yeah 1978
September I got my real estate license I
was 18 that was the year interest rates
went from 9 and 3/4 to 10% for the very
first time
ever and if it did it then and then it
went on up to 18 before it came back
down and it took it a decade to do that
reversal to go on up and then back down
uh if it did it then why can't it do it
now I mean I don't know these these
bozos continue to screw with this
they're they're going to mess it up I
mean so I wouldn't be sitting around
waiting on the outside environment to
get you ready you get ready strike while
the iron's
hot when it comes to saving up for a
house A good rule of thumb is this a
smaller down payment means you're going
to borrow more on your home obviously a
a bigger down payment means you're going
to borrow less and ultimately you're
going to pay off your home faster it'll
be a challenge but your perseverance
will pay off big time all right guys
thanks for listening and make sure to
share this with your friends in the
market for a home and don't miss the
next episode to find out which mortgage
traps you don't want to fall
in